[Applause]
that's so cool
um I found out something new that I did
not know
I didn't know that you were originally
they maybe almost had you as a judge
yeah originally when the producers Nigel
and Ken yeah were setting up the show
they had heard me on the radio here in
Los Angeles and they thought that I
might fit the panel to be up there with
whoever else was already on I guess
Simon was already on board and I don't
know who else at that point and I was
like well wait a minute I would love to
audition to be the host and so I
auditioned eventually to be the host and
I got the job so I'm happy to still have
the job I know that's
[Applause]
so I don't know that I'd be able to sit
behind the desk and just give feedback
I'd want to do that then toss the
commercial welcome back how are you you
know all the
that would be too much I like this and
likely family or like
are you we would like to have the nachos
followed by I think would you like the
veganism let's have the beef and chicken
fajitas and we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going
home